alors justement revenons à votre livret
a devant l'inter nous arrivons à la fin
du xviiie siècle et vous dites
révolution dans les familles qui sont
lentes bien entendu progressive mais
s'installe peu à peu un amour maternel
et d'ailleurs vous dites la jonction de
ces deux beaux amoureux maternelle par
une chose curieuse à cette époque alors
qu'elle comment se manifeste cette amour
maternel et ben principalement par la
prise en charge par les femmes de leurs
enfants et par mon direct des soins et
quotidien je dirais presque heure par
heure les femmes commencent à passer
leur temps avec leurs enfants et ça veut
dire non seulement l'allaitement qui
commence à redémarrer je dirai après
deux siècles d'incertitude l'allaitement
recommence les femmes restent à la
maison commence à s'occuper de la santé
des enfants
des recherches la meilleure hygiène pour
l'enfant du d'émail otage le démâtage et
alors le démâtage me sens très
intéressant parce que tant qu'un petit
bébé était dans un carcan emmailloté
serrer très fort c'était une certitude
pour celles qui sont occupées la mer à
nourrice ou n'importe qui d'autre que
ils n'arrivent revient au bébé et
qu'elle pouvait vaquer à ses affaires
tranquille et que ce bébé donc
emmailloté si vous abusez pas
l'approcher à des portemanteaux très
haut pour que les rappelé pas attraper
de sac à dos mais je crois qu'il faut
pas être fataliste l'image est une chose
vous faire de ça mais c'est aussi
quelque part un geste même d'attention
bébé pour pas qu'ils soient mangés par
les figues ou de la vapeur ça prouve
bien la condition si misérable enfin je
veux dire de ce conditionnement
justement qu'avaient ces femmes ccc
simple mais ceci dit je dis ça parce que
ça souvent est interprétée comme une
preuve de dureté des nouvelles normes
donc être passé dans le monde tant est
un enfant des maillotins enfants qu'il
faut surveiller ses enfants qu'il faut
feriez tout le temps pour pas qu'ils
tombent pour pas qu'ils se fassent mal
et qui surveille c'est le maire et
d'autre part un haut fond des maillots
tessin faut qu'on peut toucher et
embrasser câliner et l'enfant des
métiers peut toucher sa mère et c'est
tout à fait propice à l'amour au contact
charnel entre la mère et l'enfant qui
n'existe pas de fête quand l'enfant
était emmailloté il ya ce progrès glee j
il ya par exemple quelque chose de
nouveau c'est l'obsession maternelle de
la santé de l'enfant
c'est la volonté qui survivent et qui
survivent non seulement en appelant de
médecins par exemple l'idée beaucoup de
traités de médecine ont fait vacciner on
prend des tanneries si on s'inquiète
quand il est malade c'est comme un
phénomène très nouveau donc vraie
attention quels sont les réseaux east
historique que le mix sociale qui
explique cette transformation
je crois pas qu'ils aient une vision
cela faisait plusieurs raisons et
peut-être celle que j'ai non ce ne sont
pas les seules petites un lattis
d'autres mais il me semble en tous les
cas qu'une première raison est assez
loin des femmes s'éloigner du problème
des femmes et qui pourtant a dû jouer à
gran rossé certaines raisons que le
niveau politique c'est à dire que au 18e
on se rend compte et sous la pression
des économistes notamment qu' un état
doit être prête riches et puissants doit
être peuplée et où 18e ou via les
premiers balbutiements de la démographie
on a l'impression que la population
stagne au 10e alors qu'elle est en
légère un léger progrès et ça devient
une obsession pour les hommes
responsables de la nation dit mme il
faut faire quelque chose à mes enfants
il faut faire des enfants il y accéder
en scène de michel debré il faut faire
des autorités et de dons que faire des
enfants comme dit michel debré il faut
conserver ce qui n'est ce pas ce qu'une
note a été assez forte au 10e même très
fort mais comme il en meurt 1 sur 2
avant dix ans et bien ça stagne à peu
près et alors c'est une mode une raison
très forte qui fait que les hommes
responsables de l'état du roi de louis
15 louis saez après d'ailleurs aux
économies à tous les mythes 18e le
moddeur fait il faut que les enfants
survit et pas tous les moyens les pieds
d'autres raisons moi qui me paraît
importante que vous avancez note livre
c'est l'idée d'un seul coup qu'il faut
faire son bonheur sur terre peut-être
avant de faire son salut au ciel alors
ça c'est une deuxième raison je crois
que c'est ce que j'appelle pointe la
nouvelle philosophie qui est la
philosophie du bonheur c'est à dire que
on finit si vous voulez avec l'idéologie
du dix septième cartésienne cetera à
savoir l'homme doit d'abord chercher son
bonheur ici sur terre
au lieu d'attendre la béatitude
éternelle et cette nouvelle idée qu'on
peut trouver sa joie de vivre sur la
terre
va tout doucement conduire les hommes à
se dire mais après tout on va trouver le
bonheur c'est d'abord à 2 dans la
famille cdapp et donc c'est le
commencement des mariages d'amour du
sentiment sein de la famille
et si vous voulez c'est l'idée que le
bonheur ça se trouve dans la cellule
familiale avec sa femme et ses enfants
ça c'est une deuxième raison c'est donc
cette nouvelle idéologique d'honneur sur
la terre et la troisième qui me semblent
considérables c'est le fait que pour la
première fois dans l'histoire en
excellente les cas les sommes que
j'appelle les intermédiaires de l'état
c'est à dire les médecins les
philanthropes les moralistes et même les
lieutenants de police voire vont
s'adresser directement aux femmes ce qui
est la première fois et pour leur dire
mesdames vous avez une tâche essentielle
à remplir
c'est de vous occuper de vos enfants
vous êtes donc élevée oui vous les
responsables la nation voilà un rôle
inuit et va jouer vous allez être fêtés
si vous êtes des bonnes mères
gardez-les est élevé l'est et assurer
leur santé physique à la télé et vous
aurez droit à la reconnaissance de
l'année c'est le sentiment de nature
aussi oui alors qu' à rousseau qui
intervient là dedans y'a rousseau et
tous ces justes aux all blacks gravitent
autour même discours de cousseau c'est à
dire écoutez vous avez oublié que votre
nature de femme était d'abord maternelle
et donc peu à peu leur a permis d'avoir
d'instinct l'internât on leur a dit
qu'elle avait un instinct andré langaney
voulait devrait vous les posez une
question parce que quand même malgré
tout il y a une chose qui est était un
an ce que vous dit tout à l'heure sur
l'apparition du souci de la reproduction
de la population et quand vous faites
remonter à l'apparition de la
démographie à une démarche scientifique
je crois n'est pas tout à fait exact au
moins au sur le plan de l'évolution de
l'ensemble des sociétés humaines sur un
sur la planète pour qu'une société se
maintiennent surtout lorsqu'elle est
très peu nombreuses il faut qu'elle
progrès il faut qu'elles aient des
enfants il faut qu'elles maintiennent à
la fois sa culture et sa population et
cela c'est un souci qui je crois est
très ancien qui se rencontrent dans la
plupart des peuples de la terre très
éloigné de notre pensée notre démarche
scientifique alors voudrait peut-être
retourner la question et vous vous
demandez ce qui vous fait penser qu'il a
pu y avoir pendant deux siècles trois
siècles une période pendant laquelle on
a pu
pas se soucier de la population parce
que je crois que c'est un souci quasi
universelle de toutes les populations
lauriane quand même fallu que les gens
soient suffisamment nombreux qu'ils
aient l'impression du nombre et du
maintien de la population pour pouvoir
se comporter tel qu'ils l'ont fait parce
que je crois quand même que cette
absence de comportement maternel et de
soucis des enfants est quelque chose de
tout à fait exceptionnel dans toutes les
sociétés humaines parce que c'est les
condamner à plus ou moins long terme à
la disparition surtout en cas de forte
mortalité infantile par ya deux choses
premièrement on procède à des
dénombrements à partir de colbert allons
on ne s'intéresse pas au nombre exact
parce que c'est très difficile pour des
raisons administratives comme vous savez
et donc les premiers dénombrement
compter combien on laisse une répulsion
qui naît avec colbert et comme vous
savez aussi les résultats obtenus par
colbert ont été très insuffisants très
mal fait et on a recommencé au xviiie au
début du 18e et c'est le grand
dénombrement qui est publié par vauban
et le problème c'est que tout le 18e va
continuer à va ce recompte est et en mer
on recompte mal on arrive s'il voulait à
des chiffres qui stagne non je voudrais
dire autre chose nous dit que c'est un
comportement exceptionnel
vous savez qu'en europe occidentale
l'angleterre à gide les mêmes c'est que
les maires anglaise ce qu'on dit de la
même façon que en allemagne a aussi un
problème d'abandon des enfants marc
lemmer pour qu'on vous parlait d'une
société occidentale et ce n'est pas le
seul pays
vous parlez seulement du conte à
l'échelon national mais il se fait un
autre et j'ai peut-être une réponse
partielle alors à la question de les
poser et se fait aussi un autre niveau
dans la france rurale il se faisait au
niveau du village
on savait très bien combien on était
combien survivaient et peut-être que là
lorsque le village était petits c'était
la même situation que celle que l'on
observe dans les villages d'afrique ou
d'amérique latine où on a souci d'avoir
à ses enfants pour que le village se
maintiennent en vie la situation est
différente mais il ya quand même un
niveau auquel on se compte c'est celui
de la famille et dans beaucoup de
populations on est très angoissé d'avoir
des descendants et surtout des
descendants mâles si la société est pas
traîné
et comment se fait-il justement que ce
souci n'est pas été présent est présent
avec la même intensité mais j'aime pas
qu'il faut distinguer entre deux shows
c'est à dire avec le souci est familiale
et de devront la volonté de reproduction
interne la famille et à soucis
politiques étatiques et économique tout
dire que la livraison ne se fait pas
aussi bien entre la famille et le
pouvoir politique et le fait qu'il n'y a
pas doute
historiquement c'est tout à fait exact
pour la première fois on a envie de se
compter ça se trouve au 17e et qu'on
recommence ou 18 heures ça n'a pas eu
lieu avant alors c'est vrai qu'au niveau
du village de la famille on sait très
bien faire c'est con mais comme vous
savez les communications sont n'ont pas
de sens à cette époque et ferme le
rapport entre la cellule familiale le
village est l'état nation c'est tout à
fait différent
les 162 contesté l'apparition donc des
bonnes mères au xviiie siècle
à la fin je ne conteste pas vraiment
parce que c'est vrai que ça correspond à
une libération et du corps et de la
nature le xviiie siècle tout d'un coup
les femmes abandonnent les corsets
abandonne les jardins à la française
deviennent les jardins luxuriants pour
la nature s'épanouit et s'épanouir et le
romantisme prône l'amour entre hommes et
femmes alors qu'avant c'étaient des
mariages de raison nous renouons ça je
ne discute pas du tout mais peut-être
que dans la mède l'emmaillotage
correspond aussi au carcan que portaient
les gens eux mêmes les adultes ils
avaient des corsets il avait des crampes
phrases comme ça et on les paie pas dans
les campagnes non pas dans les campagnes
mais dans l'est dans la société urbaine
et bourgeoise il avait de grandes des
vies des costumes très gênant et pour
embrasser son enfant comment est ce
qu'on pouvait faire préparer une fraise
qui depuis l'époque qui nous consultent
c'était le début du xviie quand même
vous commencez à ce moment là bon cela
dit
moi je ne suis pas là pour discuter des
points de détail est de développer
j'avais dans la tête mais je pense que
vous pensez que l'amour maternel a
toujours existé mais oui bien sûr avec
plus ou moins de manifestations
extérieures et plus ou moins d'intensité
peut être dû au mode c'est vrai mais je
conteste la la conclusion des jacobins à
terme en disant l'instinct maternel
n'existe pas parce que comme je veux
dire andré langaney un enfant un petit
enfant d'hommes était quelque chose de
tout à fait démunis et la mer au début
de sa vie c'est comme la chienne avec
son petit chien comme la ti la chatte
avec son petit chat elle le tourner lui
retourner le net soit justement elle ne
voit pas il est aussitôt est élue elle
enlève l'enfant 10 avril s est amené ça
n'empêche pas que l'instinct maternel
reste quand même et commenter c'est pas
parce que tout d'un coup il ya un tronc
ben oui c'est pas parce qu'il ya un trou
momentanée d'un siècle ou deux internet
c'est la survie des enfants ce n'est pas
le comportement de la mère à leur égard
c'est surtout l'envié il faut qu'il y
ait une éducation il faut qu'il y ait
alors la maternelle de l'enfant mais qui
peut être assumée par quelqu'un d'autre
dans la somme et là les délais
d'instruction
bien sûr son délégué il faut bien sûr
que les soins insiste mais ce ne sont
plus des soins maternels
enfin le lait de la mère ou le lait la
nourrice sur le plan les musiques c'est
la même chose et c'est toujours à
l'émail amour fasse fi ça se tissent au
fil des associés au fil des ans
mais alors qu'est-ce que c'est comme en
amour il faut dans paraître quand ya pas
de relation n'a parlé ailleurs au moment
d'en parler il n'apparaît pas mais
l'instinct maternel exister quand même
puisqu'il a dit il
il analysé disons qu'elle est soumis à
terrebonne pas du tout mais votre
conclusion quelle culture générale alors
là je la protège tout on va peut-être
venir